what's up everyone big week here at geek
culture we've been doing camera reviews
lens reviews a lot of tech reviews and
we are not done yet
24 hours ago i received the 2021 16-inch
macbook pro that is pretty much
maxed out
the m1 max chipset 10 core cpu 32 core
gpu 64 gigabytes unified memory and two
terabytes of onboard storage
this is a beast of a machine i am super
pumped to try this out i'm going to give
you guys a full review in the coming
weeks because this has to go back but i
want to give you my first impressions
because if you're like me and you're out
there you're debating should i get
the macbook pro with the m1 pro chipset
or the m1 max chipset 14 inch 16 inch or
just stick with my 13 inch macbook pro
or macbook air what should i do i'm
going to try to answer some of those
questions for you in this video then of
course in the full review i will really
push this through its paces 8k video 6k
video 4k video multiple timelines audio
photos 100 megapixel medium format
images editing and tiff editing in raw
throwing them in various different apps
we're going to try to burn this machine
out if we can if we can do that that
will be my full review but for now we're
going to pull it back a little bit and
we're just going to talk about this
machine for someone who may want to buy
it today tomorrow or next week so with
that let's get down to talking about the
16-inch macbook pro okay first
impressions i want to tell you is that
it is a little bit larger than the
previous 16-inch macbook pro that came
out a couple years back okay the reason
being i think apple's learned some
lessons along the way they wanted to go
slim and sleek for a lot of the a lot of
years with their pro machines but that
doesn't really work with pro machines
why because pro users need ports they
need power they need efficiency they
need a machine that is going to be like
a desktop replacement that they can take
with them if they need to go somewhere
but they don't want to sacrifice now the
macbook pro 16 inch does that
predominantly well a couple things i'll
talk about uh which i wish was improved
on or they could have done a little bit
better but that or these are just minor
things but for the most part this
machine is everything a pro user has
wanted from apple for the past i would
say three to four years in my personal
opinion let's talk about the ports this
is a big deal for us users out there we
now have three
thunderbolt 4 ports which is of course
backwards compatible usb-c and
thunderbolt 3 et cetera et cetera et
cetera we have an hdmi port we have a
headphone jack we have an sd card reader
as well and we have magsafe which is
back in the game i love magsafe it saves
you if you knock your cable on accident
from your laptop flying all over the
place you know previously it was usbc
great it charges fast but if you knock
your laptop on accident there goes your
laptop hopefully you got quick hands to
catch it otherwise it's a very expensive
drop but magsafe protects you against
that now in terms of the ports i'm glad
we have more ports however
now that it's thicker
why only three thunderbolt 4 ports i
mean i'm looking at my imac uh m1
version right here it's got four ports
it's got two thunderbolt 4 ports and two
usb c ports
why couldn't we have that apple or even
three thunderbolt 4 ports and two usbc
ports because you know you need to
connect things to this device you know
it's not just a couple things here and
there because yes we've got the sd card
reader so i don't need my sd card reader
anymore i don't need that dongle it is
gone
but
if i need to hook up a couple other
drives to this because i need it for
work then i need to hook up my zoom f6
which i use for audio then maybe
something else i'm pretty much maxed out
again on a pro machine that is not cheap
apple
why not more thunderbolt 4 usb c ports
why what holds you back in the engineer
room what makes who's in there is
telling us that we cannot have this i
don't know but anyway that is my only
complaint about the ports on this
machine hdmi is great if you use hdmi
the sd card reader is fantastic however
i'm testing cameras we're slowly going
to cf express type b and type a but sd
card is still the predominant that is
the main card most people use so it's
there it's great i'm happy that it's
there because it makes my life a lot
easier to transfer images and audio into
my machine in terms of the battery life
on this now they're saying 20 to 21
hours in terms of video playback i
haven't had that chance to test this out
but i can tell you this sips juice
unless you're pushing proapps this sips
juice i was last night i was on the web
i was watching some video youtube and
all that great stuff and i mean i didn't
plug this thing in since i got it
put it you know put it to sleep open up
this morning and
i mean i don't know if there was even a
fraction of the bar missing it was
beautiful it was a thing of beauty then
i was loading up all my apps today
photoshop capture one lightroom uh all
the others uh luminar ai topaz de nois
sharpening gigapixels loading that all
up pushing it a little bit editing some
images and the battery was still
relatively good so i'm impressed with
the battery life on this thing so if
you're worried about battery life on a
macbook pro do not be apple's also learn
their lesson and giving us some decent
battery life in a pro machine i'm liking
where apple's going with this whole pro
thing i'm getting it because previously
they're treating the pro machines like
they're consumer machines and they're
not now we're getting pro battery life
pro form pro ports and we've got to talk
about the display i'll get to the
keyboard i'll get to the speakers we'll
get to all that we gotta talk about this
xdr displaying this with promotion it is
beautiful it is stunning it is what i
wanted in a display as a matter of fact
i if i got this machine and you know
when you're editing at home 16 inches is
a good size display but i like a big
display i like 24 27 even 32 inches and
larger because when you're editing video
and editing photos you want to zoom in
and see the details and you can do that
beautifully on this display but you know
what make me sad it's if i had to plug
this into an external display because no
external display except apple's own
would be as beautiful as this
and i would be sad
because it is
absolutely stunning to use
it really is
i mean the colors are fantastic the
promotion
just like your ipad pro
it's just ah
it's a thing of beauty i absolutely love
it talking about the display we got to
talk about the notch people complain
about the notch honestly folks the notch
is not a big deal and i'll tell you why
in just a bit because i'm going to give
you a sample of what it's like to record
footage out of the camera on this which
is now 1080p
that's right
gone are the days of those really low
resolution webcams we've had in previous
macbook pros and macbook airs it is gone
as a matter of fact i'm gonna roll some
footage of me talking to that camera so
you can hear the microphones in the
macbook pro as well as the video quality
right now okay we are testing out the
camera on the macbook pro 16 inch and it
reminds me a lot of the camera that's on
my imac m1 version which a lot of people
compliment me on so i guess i'll get
those same compliments here on this
macbook pro version and the mics inside
of this uh laptop as well because a lot
of people love the mics on the previous
16-inch macbook pro so i'm guessing that
is carrying over to this
but i gotta say i like it and you know
what i get the notch in the disregard
because if you're doing web conferencing
you know it's very hard to concentrate
on a small green dot or a small lens but
when you have this little notch there it
does
make your eyes gravitate towards this
area more so it's more engaging when
you're talking to that person on the
other side of the pc or mac so yeah it's
got some benefits besides design anyway
those are my thoughts on the camera on
the macbook pro okay
now we've got that set up let's move on
to the keyboard the keyboard is
beautiful it's that magic keyboard we
enjoyed the magic keyboard some people
didn't like the butterfly keyboard i
didn't bother me either which way but
some people really love the magic
keyboard and it is here also what has
changed that touch bar is now gone it's
gone it's gone it's gone back to the you
know years past where the actually have
actual physical function keys honestly
speaking i did not mind the touch bar as
as a matter of fact some ways it was a
benefit to me
but there were people that had a
adverse reaction to the touch bar i
don't know people get emotional about
these things but it's gone will apple
ever bring it back maybe they will in
the future maybe it will be more
enhanced who knows but we all now have
physical function keys which is great to
have in terms of the keyboard one thing
you're going to notice is there's no
more button to sort of dim the lights on
the keyboard it's just lit up and it's
all uniform it's all beautiful and it
all just seems to be seamless so as a
matter of fact when i'm looking at the
keyboard here in my studio where i've
got ample light coming here
i don't really notice the keyboard is
lit up but it actually is so it's very
sensitive to the light around you and it
just adjusts um ever so much so if
you're in a dark room you're going to
see it well it's well lit if you're in a
brighter room it will just dim down
enough but it's still lit a little bit
but it's not as uh you know you can't
turn it off like you could before so i
don't know maybe that will be something
that can change in a firmware update or
something or maybe it'll be a software
but i don't know but you can't turn it
off from what i see currently speakers
on this machine
look if you tried the 2019 16-inch
macbook pro everybody was raving about
the speakers on that and rightfully so
they were phenomenal for a laptop it
didn't it didn't sound like a laptop
speaker system it's not like something
you would an external speaker system
that you would buy from you know the
apple store or something and hook it up
to your laptop it was that good
this is even better
absolutely beautiful i don't know if you
will be able to hear the audio i'll try
my best to try to give you an eye an
idea here uh
and turn this on real quick i'll play a
youtube video because you know obviously
for copyright situations
play something from
geek culture here
let's go to our videos
play this one all right guys something
just dropped in the studio that i think
you guys are going to enjoy especially
if you want something that is going to
be a conversation starter
over the top this is me talking about
the way i'm cool
we've got the razer zephyr
mask this is an rgb air purifier night
so as you can tell right now it's loud
it's clear it's crisp as a matter of
fact it was it's very much similar to
what i'm uh using on the imac right here
to hear my audio now i would say the
imac might be slightly louder than this
but this is very clean audio uh so there
you go i mean i would love to play more
for you but of course for copyright
situations i can't but i'll try to do
something in the full review to give you
more of an idea of what this sounds like
now in terms of uh performance on this
i'm gonna tell you this this is just
based on my first 24 hours photoshop
breeze and i'm editing gfx100s images
out there they're about 200 megabytes
raw 600 megabytes in terms of a tip file
size so they're very large there's no
hiccup there's no stuttering you zoom in
on the image it looks beautiful it's
fantastic uh topaz de noise works great
a sharpening works great there's no
stutter it is very very fluid even
luminar ai
works relatively well and lubiner ai is
pretty taxing on the computer system and
it does a decent job on this macbook pro
there's no issues at all with it
so
in terms of photo editing you're going
to love this machine you're going to
love it if you're using something that's
lower megapixels than what i'm using for
medium format it's going to just chug
through it with a breeze as a matter of
fact i've not even heard this fan system
kick on once and i had photoshop
lightroom luminar ai and topaz de noise
open all at the same time and also final
cut in the background so i'm running
some apps and they're all set it's all
working beautifully on that so i had one
person message me today and asking me
well what's it like to use microsoft
word in powerpoint i'm like
it's like a thing of beauty there's no
issues it's just that's nothing to this
machine that's
snacks
it needs more
so
talking about which one should you get
okay let's break it down for you
the m1 chipset for the most part like
the imac and one that i have right here
is a fantastic machine the only downside
i find on this machine is that it only
has 16 gigabytes of unified memory now
at the beginning when i first got it
that was great but as i've been getting
more into pro applications i'm finding
myself getting low memory warnings pop
up on the screen i have to actually shut
down apps in the background to continue
working on certain projects which is not
optimal especially when you're working
on video or photos you don't want to
lose what you're you're editing right so
that is where i would think the m1
chipset if you're a pro user and you're
going to use a lot of these apps that
i've been talking about through this
video
i would recommend going to the m1 pro
now the difference between the m1 pro
and the m1 max isn't that big of a
difference on paper now i haven't tried
the m1 pro but looking at the specs
online if you're a hobbyist for example
and you're just dabbling with a little
bit of photo editing and video editing
you know 4k
6k you can still do 8k with the m1 pro
not it can be an issue now the max
chipset
is for those
that need
top of the line performance when your
job requires it when you're editing you
know you're doing autocad hardcore
autocad you're doing you know
3d rendering you're doing
vr you're really getting into
movie editing and special effects after
effects and motion and you're really
pushing these apps to their limits
editing aka a lot or even 6k or you're
doing multiple timelines i mean when
you're really just going into it that's
where the m1 max is going to come into
play for you okay now of course there
will be some of you liked it that have
the money and the means to buy this
because you want the best of the best
get this laptop you are good i
personally are good for three years or
more but those are my initial thoughts
on the m1 macbook pro 16 inch
i'm excited to take it through its paces
i'm going to really try
to bog this machine down just have some
fun i'm not going to go through geek
bench scores and all that stuff because
honestly i don't believe in it i believe
in real world usage and actually testing
machine with real applications not just
some simulation tests out there to tell
me what it's going to work with and what
it's not going to work with because i've
tried those things before and sometimes
they give you some great numbers but
when it comes down to actual usage it's
not always the case anyway those are my
thoughts on the macbook pro let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below any questions you have for me hit
me up in the comments i'll try to answer
them for you with that follow us on
facebook subscribe to the channel like
this video help us out a lot stay safe
and i'll chat to you soon take care